il y as qui devait être est clair et qui
s'est transformé en guerre d'usure
lancé en janvier 2015 par le prince
héritier saoudien mohammed bin salman
son objectif est clair remettre au
pouvoir le président yéménite renversé
par les rebelles houthi ali abdallah
saleh
cette opération devait selon ses propres
mots ne durer que deux jours
il est appuyé par une coalition de neuf
pays menée par l'arabie saoudite et les
émirats arabes unis et les moyens
militaires déployés sont considérables
malgré cela la coalition n'est toujours
pas venu à bout des rebelles houthi
ryad a même été directement touchées par
des tirs de missiles un fiasco militaire
au prix de bombardements meurtriers qui
touchent durement les civils aux
disparus s'ajoutent les millions de
déplacés et la famille provoquée par le
blocus mis en place par la coalition
une situation décrit par l'onu comme la
pire crise humanitaire au monde
la situation au yémen est catastrophique
c'est la pire crise humanitaire sur
terre avec 16 millions de personnes en
réelles situations d'urgence et 5
millions qui souffrent ou vraiment la
famine sur donc si nous n'obtenons pas
l'argent dont nous avons besoin est le
carburant
nous allons probablement avoir la pire
famine ont jamais connu
devant cette situation plusieurs pays
décident d'arrêter leurs ventes d'armes
à l'arabie saoudite
c'est le cas notamment de l'italie et
des etats-unis joe biden
la france elle reste pour le moment
muette en 2019
elle occupait la troisième place sur le
podium des vendeurs d'armes fournissant
ainsi 7,9 pour cent du marché mondial le
secteur de l'industrie de défense est un
secteur très important pour la
technologie française et pour notre
économie pour nos emplois
je n'ai aucune information me permettant
d'assurer que ces victimes civiles le
son du fait des armes françaises
acculé dans ses positions sur le terrain
militaire est affaibli par les
défections de ses principaux alliés
internationaux
l'arabie saoudite a proposé ce lundi
un cessez le feu total à outils
proposition rejetée car elle tombe à un
moment où leurs adversaires sont sur le
point de prendre la ville stratégique de
m'arrive